in Germany they are going to have public
nudist
spaces in the city not just the beaches
that's right
they're going to take suburban naked
zones around the city
where people be green to sunbathe naked
we don't have any images for this sorry
but our or anything like that 24/online
hey i'd just athletically good but
this is where a comment I G notebook
thank you urban megan's only under the
under
yes so there this started because the
there with an expiration up legislation
per nude
sunbathing in Bavaria a which Munich is
the capital
and city leaders headed to decide can
people stripped in public now or what
they're just got these little
naked zones and this is literally gonna
be like there's gonna be people working
in offices and then just
you know a few feet away to make it
though and but we could never do that
good week you know and they should do in
Germany because
German Germany's up and it's always been
fucked up
and this is just another fucked up thing
like I just leads to a weird political
party doesn't know why it doesn't really
do it broke a party that's a great point
but
you were just talking about the porn
story and like when you watch porn
and then you stumble on german porn you
realize
all do you go yeah geez I hope she's OK
I while her work I can look back and
remember little bored I honestly I'm not
really sure we german porn is but every
time we've done a show at being on point
in this
someone says that about german porn and
people start going what's the deal with
her more aggressive
very progressive there's a lot of
choking ok up
Bernard yet it's not a if that mean I've
only watched like
15-20 hours okay you have to explore
el turno into you don't one other person
jack tells a great story one of the
first videos when he was given id
you know BHS one was german porn
yeah and one of the lines personal
everything said in even like
you know a baby feel so good night i
just want to be inside you and make you
feel wonderful
even that sounds hitting under pressure
but there's a line there
that was I'm gonna get it slightly wrong
but it's essentially snow but that
doesn't mean that mean
right which just again sounds like rev
up
both ride I'll make God and
only alone or she would die for a
helpful with Valeria
looked that doesn't really mean it means
that drink it up
good for you ok up
if I might buy it pleaseee good I love
where this is going
the art I think that I think that that
the major
a E comment on on our society and how we
feel about unity because
I don't think that these people that
this culture a quake
community with poor I mean there's but
yet they go with their families they go
with their little kid I
lived in Greece for a very small at a
time and we would go to the new beaches
I promise you
not only were these not you know hyper
sexual people they were not
hyper sexually attractive people rather
have people who like to be naked and it
doesn't mean anything other than that
great so in europe it's just people like
me need yeppers is here are nude beach
is it always like a lot all I am writing
by
push like yet father himself was
actually Ben you be there that's where
we met
thank God but i think is right I think
that I and II think the nudist would
would would bristle at the notion that
we want sexualized
yet their desire to be in you is there
something a little funny that the
geographic location at this that it
really is gonna be
pretty much in urban areas as if these
naked people have to get naked
like their there at work and all day
looking like I'll chink
called I Drive my love that I think that
so great yeah
yet they just keep their clothes on if I
might
anecdotally tell you a few weeks ago I
may or may not have been a clothing
optional fly
in Palm Springs and really you're
welcome and
I'll yet which option did I
and here's the thing meet these people
and many others there's probably people
out there that do it for like no other
reasons but
this particular a the hotel was just
people who just aren't feeling
just aren't feeling close so that thing
I think that these German people
there's nothing to it man so and I'll
also tell you walk around like bit
barnaby in a good guy any bill again
what's going on and that was it
they go back to his room and waters real
cold my apology
it's not a big deal yeah so and I
you know whatever you not you have any
guy say the pay
my mouth appear yeah that well you know
I'm from Kansas
so I'm I'm obviously you know a liberal
you know super open hippie
but you know if you could just excuse
that yeah that something like
its it it's not a big deal to most in
the world
yeah I did about also adds a lot to the
world and German pontiff in the park
alfresco I'm I think that's great well I
didn't know we actually had a legit
nudist on the car would not know if you
do either with what what what made you
wanna go there
worked only for a few what yet what made
you want to go
wake you to say I let me try on i think
is pretty great really yeah I know that
what brought me there
this'll be like a 440 second-story go
Arab so
I was in the desert with some friends
I'm already bored you can
shut it I than it does it with some
friends late in the day and the Republic
minerals finally got a little late for
that doll clothing I'll see what I can
do
and I call this one it is read only done
it my father I don't know about try them
there on Google I call it that hike
are you still open to you you noted
clothing paw
and look all were closed up those are
the on a big deal goes
what's your name and I said Gina and he
does we talked a few minutes with
let me call you right back so we call
you right back to those Gina
like the cut of your jib that you sound
like a really really
honest person you sound like a very
trustworthy person I like you a lot to
you wanna do
we're gonna leave you the key what 0
swear to God are you sure you just end
up at the mall burbs house
to any we thought it was going to be the
world's worst David Lynch movie but we
get there
under people there and it's like the got
it statues like these
out there that they're beautiful and we
push in the coating
open its like I can share a lot alike
well where there around
so we had an amazing time and I ever
really trustworthy VoIP
up